give you all an example I don't know if
you all know my history but I used to
run a webcam business a long time ago
don't talk about it but I had a bunch of
girls who used to sit online and talk to
guys and they had laptops right this is
a long time ago
I used to sit and say to some of the
webcam girls that say this man who is
sitting in and logging in every night
and sending you money every day and
telling you he's obsessed with you from
the other side of the world and missing
out on time with his family to sit here
and talk to you and send you money that
is more cheating than if he just went
out and banged something if he went out
and banged something and came home then
done but he's sitting here giving you
his time his money his affection that's
cheating for a man for a man to sit
there and give money and time away right
so you have to stop this idea of sexual
exclusivity yes that's for females
that's how females show their love to
men it's not how high status at least
male show their love to females